si un ha reaccionado con contundencia al
informe de la onu que denuncia
violaciones de derechos contra los
uigures en la provincia de xinjiang dice
el ministerio de exteriores que ese
informe va en contra de los deberes de
la organización y que no es más que un
cúmulo de mentiras además define el
informe como un invento que ha sido
utilizado como herramienta política por
eeuu y occidente y pide que de una vez
por todas se acabe con el doble rasero
en materia de derechos humanos china ya
había criticado a la onu el día anterior
presentando su propio informe que
triplica en hojas al original y en el
que aclara que lo que define como
centros de formación voluntaria fueron
levantados para luchar contra el
terrorismo y el extremismo en la región
y que dos años atrás habiéndose resuelto
ya esos problemas y recuperada la
armonía social fueron desmantelados el
informe de la onu no hace ninguna
referencia al genocidio una acusación
del gobierno estadounidense algo
exagerada pero sí que recoge suficientes
violaciones de derechos humanos como
para irritar a china que ve en este
asunto un intento de estabilización